there is something new and exciting at
findlay toyota who is sponsoring this
next segment and i got the call to go
check it out
[Applause]
got some big news john barr gave me a
call and he said they've got the all new
2022 toyota tundra here on the lot and
we get to check one out
[Music]
it tastes really good how many cars are
sending this week yeah
jaycee what are you doing
yes it is
it's here yes it is you actually hear it
a lot it is on the lot right out front
you didn't see on the way i didn't see
it can i go stick it though of course
you can we're going to get daryl to help
you so head outside and i'll let daryl
know you're going to be in go back
outside uh yes you need to go outside
okay i'm driving inside
thank you all right
[Applause]
there it is the 2022 this is gorgeous
yes it has arrived it is here uh we are
greatly happy about it
this is new the all-new grille all new
redesign uh the grille the engine
platform is all new twin turbo v6 uh the
bold grille redesigned the whole body
this is the platinum version uh so this
one's a pretty much loaded up as well we
have one available that's a new feature
for the tundra all new running boards
power steps from toyota directly
love it love that talk to me about the
bed is it a new bed in the back bed
comes in available long bed all new
composite so it's lighter which improves
the towing capacity of the tundra a lot
of space back here i'll tell you what be
standing up here this high i feel like
i'm the king of the world right yes
yes jc test drive yes let's do it sounds
good daryl i feel like i'm sitting in a
brand new tundra interior this seems all
new to me yes they redesigned the whole
interior from front to back
everything the dashboard the center
console back seat everything as well
this 14 inch screen this is new yes all
new and the limited and above you can
get a 14 inch screen display
comes with everything backup camera in
it as well
all new rear view mirror that monitors
what's behind you how do people get the
test drive this one and order online yes
we can test drive this one is available
at any time and then you can go online
and order one up and whatever they want
we can order it and try to get it as
best we can for them does this one have
four-wheel drive yes it does also
available on two-wheel drive i spoke to
john earlier john barr and he said it
was cool if we took it uh off-roading
you want to get down for that yes let's
do it
[Music]
[Music]
thank you again to findlay toyota for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call them at 702-566-2500
or visit findlaytoyota.com las vegas now